[Music]
so today we're here with our Julius and
are curiously seen into actionable
intelligence our Keeley's a canon group
launched about a year ago from incue
bation and today is launching their
product into market the RQ lace video
cloud platform combines enterprise video
and IOT sensor data leveraging cloud
technologies and analytics to turn
information streams into insights for
businesses optimizing operations and
improving safety so with that I'll hand
it over to Sharif and Ben to tell you
more thank you good afternoon everyone
Oh seriously come on thank you thank you
awesome so I am Sharif Mohammed
principal engineer I run the engineering
department for our Keeley's I have been
here who's our cloud and security
architect so we get to blame him for
everything that's not working pretty
much click here come on there we go so
what do we do so we our roots really
start from cloud no sorry no cloud video
surveillance on-premise and the idea was
is that we wanted to take that and put
that into the cloud and with that
thought we were kind of building out the
product and everything we realized that
you could do so much more than just
video surveillance in the cloud and with
especially the power of AI and IOT and
that correlation of the data we realize
there's so much more there
so we're boldly trying to create a new
category by the name of video IOT as a
service video cloud IOT as a service
excuse me and what we're going to talk
about today is real it's not vapor where
this these are a few screenshots of our
product our dashboard and some of the
insights that you're able to see when
you are clicking around in the in the
application
so I want you guys a dream a little bit
with me
alright imagine if there was a way for
us to be able to detect a school
shooting when it's happening or prior to
the fact that it happens to sound and
other IOT devices that we can lock down
the school immediately and react
immediately or what if there's a lost
child at an amusement park and we could
find that lost child based on what color
shirt it was wearing or pants or
whatever or even a bracelet that it may
have through beacon technology thank you
alright
what if we're able to maximize they had
revenue that retailers have through
real-time shopper analytics to see how
the shoppers are actually interacting
with the products and within the store
their traffic and all that so our goal
is to revolutionize video and IOT
intelligence and bring that together
from this era of unstructured data very
forensic and after the fact type of
thing to more of a structured and
preventative and a way to be able to
react on on the spot let me explain a
little bit more about what the
unstructured versus structured data is
so unstructured data is very blobby and
homogeneous just like water flowing it's
just going through into the cloud you
can't really do anything with it unless
you have some sort of human element
human interaction with it to tell you
what it is that's actually happening now
there are ways to be able to detect
disturbances in that field such as
motion detection but it still doesn't
give you enough you still need a human
there to tell you oh that was just a bug
like literally a bug flying on the on
the camera or it was a blurry camera
screen or is actually a human doing
something right and again it's it's
reactive it happens after the fact so
with the advent of AI and bringing
everything up to the cloud we're able to
add more structure to that
data be able to tell you what is
actually in the video that you are
seeing such as in this scenario we're
able to see there are six people running
you know that's great we're able to know
that there are actually six people there
we know it's not a blurry screen we know
there's no smudge there or something but
we know there are six people however
they're running why are they running we
don't know exactly why we still don't
have enough context to be able to react
to that right so we need a little bit
more that's where the IOT comes in and
being able to correlate all of that data
together so in this particular scenario
we know that six people were running we
know they weren't exercising because it
seemed like there was a big spike in
temperature all right we don't know what
that spike in temperature was because of
it could be a fire more than likely it's
a fire right but we're gonna be
proactive and go sound the alarm so we
get more and more people out of the
building to save lives and things like
that and then after the fact we could
always figure out forensics wise who
what where why and win right so okay now
as I said all of this stuff you can
actually do today with our product again
this is a quick demo of our product on
the left there with all that scrolling
you see our dashboard and our web portal
where you can manage settings and things
like that
also view video the middle portion that
is our thick client that is used by 24/7
operations that you can see actual real
time AI events coming through and then
on the the the furthest right side my
right that is our IO iOS or Android app
where you could actually view live video
so with that I'm gonna pass it over to
Ben and he'll talk to you guys about
architecture and high level how we do
this cool thank you
cool hey guys so we use a variety of
technologies in our platform we have
golang nodejs react Python for
tensorflow stuff as well as some C code
we're kind of polyglot we kind of give
our engineers the ability to use the
tools that they need to solve the
problem rather than just trying to smash
a square peg in a round hole it doesn't
really work very well when you try and
get into that situation
we also use Cuban Eddie's I'm gonna talk
a little bit more about that in the next
few slides kubernetes is awesome I don't
know whether you guys are familiar with
it but gke and we also happen to have
Cuban Eddie's at the edge as well very
interesting
and then finally obviously why we're all
here is Google cloud they've been
awesome to us as partners we've we have
literally two three pages worth of
requests or problems that we're trying
to solve and Trish and one over there
have been awesome
they now solve all of our problems the
other reason why we've also used Google
cloud we we tested out several different
cloud platforms can't mention their
names but at the end of the day came
down to speed and reliability and Google
won hands down there was no question
about it there was when you're dealing
with videos such a high intense kind of
data flow there's nothing the one-drop
packet or oh it's ten seconds too late
by the time it gets there we can't react
quick enough and so that's why we chose
Google as our cloud partner cool so a
quick overview of a solution we have a
variety of methods of input I guess is
the best way open up so we have a mobile
app which is mostly used by our security
guards just roaming security guards
they're running around trying to figure
out what's going on they'll get
notifications and alarms to the cell
phone we have our web client a lot of
different things are done through there
pretty much the entire anything you can
do in our thick client you can also do
in a web plan we have a thick line which
is more traditional that's where you
have kind of your normal sort of try
thing of the word I can't remember it
I'm sorry huh
security option Center I can remove the
word but it's all good
so yeah mostly they'll be using that
product hi a loss of volume video
normally 32 cameras up on one big screen
and then it kind of get down into the
IOT side of things and the the actual
device side right so cameras as we are
effectively out of incubation from
milestone we actually support about
6,000 cameras primarily through the on
viv protocol which if you're familiar
with security cameras that's very low
for us along with a variety of very
specific device drivers for the cameras
IOT device platform is completely
extensible although it's not fully open
platform yet it will eventually be open
platform so we can plug into any IOT
vendor on Prem as well as potentially
cloud to cloud integrations in the
future access control is another huge
one obviously being able to react lock
down doors or open up doors or video
verification hey someone pass through
this door hey what's going on it's
pretty interesting and then finally our
third-party integrations it's not fully
open yet we are planning on releasing a
fully open API platform it's very
interesting being able to integrate with
other sources of data we don't know what
they are yet but that's where like being
able to pull in like unstructured data
into structured data and having all
these feeds of structured data we can do
so much more whether it be analytics
over the top of that or whether it's
just reactive elements okay so here's
our architecture we GK in the cloud of C
I talked about before and also we
actually run Cuban Eddie's at the edge
and there's something I kind of say for
this slide
Cuban Eddie's is very very interesting
it allows us to deploy micro services at
the edge as well as in the cloud and
then your much quicker at reacting from
a develop standpoint being up to fix
certain things but also being able to
deploy upgrades on the fly they go down
they come up with with very little
interruption to the customer there's no
no longer you're downloading firmware
updates or Windows updates it's all kind
of just done live and switched
hot-swappable is great not being able to
do that in a security platform is
insanely useful it's the best way I can
put it cool so quick hi high-level view
we have a video micro service that sits
on the edge that's actually where all
our camera drivers live so it's all of
our data in which is unstructured which
then pushes it to the video proxy our
video proxy then manages we use Google
Storage we store all that stuff there we
have then have our AI ml flow and work
flow we convert that unstructured data
to structured data as Sharif said
earlier we also have our IOT devices
again all the drivers and devices live
down there
at the edge all the devices connect on
Prem or in on the cloud it does live on
the gke side as well but primarily right
now it's all at the gateway we use cloud
IOT core obviously that's kind of one of
the big things here it's save us about a
month of development time building off
of IOT core it's already hardened it's
already secure we use the MQTT socket
base if anyone's interested we don't use
the HTTP push it it just had all the
features we needed at the time and the
fact that it automatically supported
private public key exchange and all that
so it just made make so much sense
obviously with cloud IOT we use pub/sub
to transport all of our messages
similar surround it a bit MQ and Kafka
just messaging platform and then the
next one is our processor how many of
you guys have heard of gdpr how many of
you have to deal with it like actual
real-life it yeah yeah so one of the
interesting things with IOT later is you
don't actually know what kind of data is
actually coming in we've built a
platform with our drivers we actually
have to categorize that data before it
comes in and we actually have to parse
out and make sure that we can utilize it
in certain situations so we've got a
whole framework and a legal framework
around this separate pieces which allow
us to say hey if this data is coming in
from Germany it can't leave the country
so we have to store it in a German data
center that kind of like rules based
engine based on geolocation it's pretty
intense
it was pretty interesting find so that's
how we kind of handled that just by
classifying the data and then being able
to move it and then based on that
classification depending on what we can
do with it we can either store it we can
just drop it we store all of our
historical data in bigquery that's where
we can do statistical analysis like over
time but we also then also like to pass
some of that information on to our
real-time engine which is in-house built
function as a service style system we
can choose to send it to this or not
obviously anyone familiar with some of
the legal ramifications of GDP are you
may not be able to pass it to users so
we may actually have to just drop it
Freeman gets there so the real-time
engine what it can do or take in
multiple sensors so it could be coming
from our AI ml services could be coming
from our IT services and we can kind of
based on a series set of rules or
potentially replumb it back into any
kind of engine so it's kind of an action
and anything to anything engine you know
weird sense away but we can kind of take
in lots of different types of data and
then either reprocess it in a different
form or then take that form and then
action upon it back out either via an
IOT data sensor or change the
configuration somewhere on our platform
to help provide more actionable insights
[Music]
you